Transcriber: Leen AlAli
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
آلاء عدنان مسعود متخرجة
من ماجستير الأكاديمية البحرية،
و إدارة أعمال من جامعة أبوظبي،
تنمية موارد بشرية، كلية الإمارات.
أتشرف وسعيدة جداً أنني موجودة معكم اليوم.
أحببت أن اتكلم عن دور المرأة في التعليم.
بالإضافة لدراستي في مجال إدارة الأعمال،
عملت كمعلمة في مدرسة دولية
لمدة سبع سنوات.
و أحببت أن أدمج ما بين
إدارة الأعمال و مجال التعليم.
و اكتشفت أنه بطريقة
ما من الممكن أن نجعل الطفل
مبدعاً أو منتجاً.
إن المدرسة في دورها ممكن
أن تجعل الطفل يصل إلى ما يريده.
ومن تجربتي الشخصية
فإن كلمة واحدة من المدرّسة
قادرة ان  تغيّر حياة طفل
ومستقبله بالكامل .
فأنا اكتشفت أننا يجب
أن نتفهم نقاط الضعف والقوة للطفل.
ونبعده عن فكرة انه
هو الوسيلة لتحقيق أحلامنا،
تجد الكثير مننا يريد ابنه أن يكون
طبيباً إذ لم يستطع هو أن يحقق حلمه.
ويحاول أن يحقق جميع
أحلامه من خلال هذا الطفل.
وهنا يضغط على هذا الطفل
ويجعله تحت الضغط،
ويفقده حس الإبداع والتميز.
أما لو أنه يجعله صاحب القرار وصاحب الفكرة،
فيصبح قادراً على أن يبدع
ويغير ويصل إلى ما يريده،
والذي يتمناه هو.
أما بالنسبة لنا نحن في إدارة الأعمال
درسنا نظرية أن الموظف مثلاً الذي
يكون تحت الرقابة هو الذي ينتج أكثر،
وهو الذي يعمل أكثر
من الموظف الذي بطبيعته يحب العمل.
حينما طبقنا النظرية على طلاب في المدرسة،
وجدت أن الطلاب الذين
نعطيهم القوة ونستمع لهم ونشعر بهم،
هم الطلاب الذين ينتجون أكثر
ومعدلهم الدراسي ازداد.
هنا اكتشفت أنه كلما تجعل
هذا الطفل أو الطالب
يتميز بقدراته دون مقارنته
أو وضعه تحت الضغط
مع أقربائه زملائه في المدرسة
و تضعه تحت ضغط أنه
لو كان شاطراً في الرياضيات مثلاً،
يجب أن يكون شاطرا في
الكيمياء والبيولوجيا أيضاً.
لا، لو كان شاطراً في مادة فنحن نلقي الضوء
على هذا الموضوع و نخرج أحسن ما عنده
ونستطيع أن نوصله إلى ما يريده
دون وضعه تحت ضعط،
و دون تهديده و دون تعنيفه.
أنا أرى أن دور المرأة في تربية
الطفل هو من أهم أدوار المرأة في المجتمع.
وللأسف الشديد لمّا درست و قرأت
وجدت أن نسبة الطلاق في مصر
ونسبة الأم العزباء أو الأب الأعزب
أو الناس الذين عندهم مشاكل، عالية جداً.
من هنا فكرت أنه كيف ممكن
أن نكون يد العون لهذا الطفل،
كيف من الممكن أن نساعد
لننشئ جيل لا يخاف،
يكون عنده حرية الرأي اويعلم كيف يتناقش.
ألا يقضي 18 سنة من حياته يتعلم
في المدرسة قراءة و كتابة و لغة،
وبالنهاية  يفتقر أن يتعامل مع الناس
وأن يعرض وجهة نظره.
لا، أنا فكرت انه نحن ممكن
أن ندعم هذا الطالب أو الطفل
و ندعم المرأة و نعطيها قوة و نجعلها تكون
هي بصيص الأمل الموجود للأجيال القادمة،
بدعمنا للمرأة و بدعمنا للطفل،
ممكن أن نصل بمصر لأعلى المراحل،
و نجعلها تكون منافسة بين دول العالم.
يجب أن يكون هناك دمج
ما بين الأفكار العلمية،
حيث يجب أن يتعلم الطالب
أن يكتب و يقرأ و يتعلم لغات،
بالإضافة إلى أن يكون عنده مهارات الحياة.
ركزت على ما تقوله د.ماريا منتسوري كانت
تقول (ان عالمنا أصابه من التمزق ما يكفيه،
فلو استمر التعليم بنقل المعارف
و المعلومات من جيل إلى جيل
سنقف يائسين ولن تستطيع
أن نتطور بأي خطوة للأمام)
فقررت أني أدمج ما بين د.منتسوري
و ما بين العالميين و ما بين أكثر من فكرة،
نستطيع أن نصل فيها للطفل و نساعد
فيها الأم و نكون يد العون،
وأن نمسك الطفل هذا مع الأم
و نوصله إلى بر الأمان،
لنستطيع جعله يعيش مع العولمة.
كما نعرف، نحن نعيش
في قرية صغيرة جداً.
لو أن الطفل والأم لم يستطيعا مواكبةالتغيير
و أن يكونا قادرين على هذا التغيير المستمر،
سنبقى نحن في الخلف و يكون هناك أمامنا
دول متقدمه كثيراً، ولكن أنا مؤمنة جداً
أن إرادتنا و قوتنا
و أن مصر بقيادتها الحكيمة،
وبالناس المسؤولة عن التعليم
سنصل بمصر للقمم،
ونستطيع مواجهة كل المشاكل في العالم
و نكون في المقدمة دائماً.
( تصفيق )